all right up next is Fred in Kentucky hi
Fred welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up uh unfortunately I the
one that had to replace one of our cars
wasn't quite prepared for it to happen
this fast and I I refuse to take a car
loan so just hoping I could get a little
advice from you good I like it so far
so game money saved emergency fund which
is taken a hit the past couple months
due to cars so it's actually down to
about five thousand I've got an
inherited IRA account that I don't want
to get into other than that retirement
accounts which I'm not going to touch
those for sure how much is over here at
an IRA about eighty thousand what's your
household income roughly ninety okay and
the current car what's the deal with it
we have literally run the wheels off of
it it is I I won't tell you to make four
for fear of that but it's a vehicle with
about two hundred and fifty thousand
miles on it and it is just done okay is
it running
um it's running it's actually my wife's
vehicle and I'm a little under the point
that I'm uneasy to let her to keep
driving it okay Wow
I mean with the income you have it
sounds like you have no debt right I
have no debt
the problem is self-inflicted oh what a
every extra dollar that I get I pack it
away into either my for one or my Roth
IRA which was which was which was a
mistake given that you needed to be
saving to replace your wife's car okay
I'm with you on correct so let's stop
everything for three months and pile up
10 grand and buyer a car and you drive
the old limp mobile while she drives
your car okay
I mean three months you could with Noah
with no contributions to anything make a
90 grand a tight budget in three months
you ought to be able save ten grand
making ninety right right what happens
if the vehicle doesn't make it that long
across that bridge when I get to it I'd
probably pop that inherited IRA it's the
only thing I can hear that works or
you're gonna or you're going to clean
out your emergency fund and have
absolutely no liquidity at all which is
okay but you're still going to only have
a $5,000 car and you're probably around
an upgrade her car in six months later
anyway you're not going to put her in a
$5,000 car permanently no no and you
only got $5,000 did I hear that right
yep okay so um you know I think you I
think you get some duct tape and some
baling wire and let's keep that thing
running you drive it give her yours it's
a federal law anyway mama gets a good
car so you know let her drive the good
car and you drive that thing and you
just keep a running baby I mean you just
keep patching it and patching it and you
know and then whatever money you got
together let's pay cash for the thing
and buy something as quick as you can I
think 10 grand would get her a pretty
good car don't you oh yeah yeah I was
thinking 10 to 15,000 but you know we
can work our way up to the 15,000 the
problem with hitting the inherited IRA
is you can't put it back once it's out
of there is out of there and so if I'm
in your shoes I'm with you I would try
to not hit that thing but if it lays
down one month into my little three
months scenario I laid out here you may
be forced to hit that thing for enough
to get her a decent car and oh well then
you learn your lesson and you say gosh I
have to save up and pay for things other
than just investing correct and that
needs to be a better rhythm in your
financial plan but otherwise you've done
a great job well your money an excellent
job with your money is
matter-of-fact so well done sir I think
you're just a supersaver and you haven't
thought about the operations of the
household because you're so into
investing which is not a bad thing but
you know it's a course correction that
you're due for hey man thanks for the
call